I want to take a few minutes of your
time to tell you about some of the new
things that we're doing in the chrome
dev tools specifically focused on mobile
but to do that I really want to take
back the clock like two years back
before Rho debugging two years ago like
developing for mobile with something
along the lines of okay let's view it on
desktop and then I'll come over and I'll
kind of drag the window yeah okay and
then you know I'll pick up my device and
I'll type it in there okay I need to
make a change I'll come back here and
that is like it's a very slow iteration
cycle and that just slows you down and
and makes it much harder to create
compelling content so even thinking
about this and we want to make that much
better we don't want this iteration
cycles to be really fast we want it to
be it's easy to debug and develop for
mobile as it is on desktop and so I'm
gonna talk about three things today
first up remote debugging talk about the
browser on the device the real
experience over there and then talk
about bringing some of those mobile
characteristics onto the desktop and
then kind of bring it all into a
development workflow and making it fast
and fluid so first step remote debugging
so actually you know what so I got my
phone right here and I want to remote
debug it
so what I'm gonna do is come up to the
top here click on Chrome's hot dog menu
it's the official name and we'll go down
to tools and then down at the bottom
down here is inspect devices so that's
what we're gonna do now you see here and
there's a check box on discovery USB
devices this is because the discovery
and communication for devices to remote
bug is now inside chrome completely you
used to have to download the Android SDK
get the ADB binary or get a Chrome
extension
forget all that you just plug in the
device so I'll plug in mine now and all
right cool so we have looks like on my
phone I have two different Chrome's we
have chrome 32 chrome 31 I have two tabs
open here I can do inspection I can
change which tab is my active tab reload
and close I have a little bit of control
and I want to actually
open up a new tab someone is typing the
new URL right here and I'm gonna go to
news.google.com okay so it opened up on
my device and you can see it here and I
have the dev tools cool so I'm just
going to you know this is the actual dev
tools it's working it's cool it's
awesome and when I highlight you can
kind of see can you see yeah okay
probably not but I'd love to be able to
show you this and in fact you know when
we think about kind of remote debugging
it's a lot of I have my dev tools here
and then I might have a dice down here
and it's a lot of switching back and
forth and we thought that there's
probably a better way to bring what
you're looking at down here and have it
visible on the screen where your tools
are so we have right here this little
icon and this is a new feature that
we're unveiling today and it's called
screencast and we're able to bring the
screen onto the device right here
so this is really cool all right so
let's interact with this page let's
search okay I'm going to just click in
search and I'm like Google Chrome you
know what type of with my thumb's is
really slow keyboards are way faster
let's just switch over to my keyboard
here and finish this off nice alright so
I can type I can click I can scroll I
can scroll on my trackpad no problem I
want to go over to images and do my real
favorite feature here inspect element
works the way you'd want it to just pick
it with your mouse works flawlessly
really nice so there's a really cool
stuff I also have full control here of
back forward reload and I'm actually
just going to go to to a different site
let's see I'm gonna come back here focus
this other tab and we'll bring that up
so this is a cool site you might have
seen it before it's it's a beer camp
kind of advertising I'm gonna go
landscape to make this a little bit
better and one of the things that I want
to show is that this is a really cool
site we're kind of had this flip book
effect guys they include did a great job
on this but imagine it was very hard to
develop because what they're doing is
they're manipulating these CSS 3d
transforms in 3d space and kind of
changing all this and then let's show a
new kind of experimental feature that
we're still working on it's the layers
panel so here now I'm able to identify
in 3d space what this is like so I get a
live preview of these layers you heard
Tommy not talking yesterday about layers
and now I'm able to see what they look
like in a 3d representation nice yeah
you like
now they said to look out for you know
the extra information and tells you
quite a bit of stuff so right now we're
showing the position the size why it was
composited which is often a really key
piece of information also an estimate on
how much memory it has how many paints
have gone in so you get a lot of insight
especially into something like the the
GPU behavior on a device which thus far
has been kind of a black box alright so
where it come out of this so for USB
debugging just plug it in don't worry
about a TB don't worry about Chrome
extensions you're good the feature set
that's available while you're bugging is
the same very powerful feature set they
used to on desktop all that stuff
timeline memory and debugging all that's
there you can screen cast your screen
interact with it inspect type click the
clicks are translated to touches it's
it's exactly what you would expect in
port forwarding is one more but I'm
going to show that a little bit later I
wanted to ask though okay so like raise
your hands if you test your stuff on
like two devices two devices keep your
hands raised if you test yourself on ten
devices it's kind of a lot I understand
but I imagine that for everyone and
congratulations for all your 10 device
people you guys are heroes that's
serious work but I imagine that everyone
that there are more than ten devices
that come to your site right it's hard
for us to evaluate compatibility with
all those so Road debugging is very
powerful for understanding performance
characteristics network conditions
things like that but we can't do that
for every possible device that we need
to check compatibility against so on
chrome dev tools we've thought about
this and thought about what we can do
and so today I'm going to show a new
feature called mobile emulation so this
is some cool stuff and let me just show
it to you I'm gonna come over here I'm
going to open up Wikipedia the article
for emulator and I'm interested in kind
of doing some mobile so I want to change
how this is represented on mobile
devices and so you know I'm gonna try
changing the screen size
okaythat's fortunately does not you know
your a responsive kind of experience
that you want alright let's open up dev
tools now down in the bottom is a drawer
you can access it with this icon or you
can just hit escape I'm gonna do that
and you might be used to seeing the
console down here but there's a new tab
called emulation inside emulation
there's a lot of stuff there's
characteristics for the screen
resolution the device pixel ratio auto
sizing viewport user agent geolocation
good good stuff there's a lot of things
and so there's a lot there's a few
device presets in here that'll help set
all these at once so I'm actually just
going to choose this nexus 4 here and it
has a few viewport settings of its own a
device pixel ratio of 2 a user agent and
I'm just going to turn on emulation now
Wikipedia serves different markup to
mobile devices so I just need to do a
refresh first but yeah this is a little
bit more like what I'm expecting so a
standard user agent spoofing would
probably be able to you know at least
get the markup and CSS for this but
we're doing a lot more than just then
first up I can scroll and you can see as
I scroll the content for the pages I see
it sliding out of the viewport right my
cursor has changed this indicate that is
now kind of a touch cursor in fact as I
touch touch events are firing I can hold
down shift and actually do a pinch too
so I can zoom just like you would do
with your fingers and this is the exact
same viewport zooming that you would
expect and that you would see on a phone
we put a lot of effort into making sure
that the view here that you see is as
close as it is as close as you would see
on a real device and so I'm going to try
bring this over here and just remote
debug it bring it up on my phone since I
have one of these screencast hello
we'll come back to this and we're
looking pretty good so there's a lot
going in here one of the things that I
want to point out is that there are in
some cases so you can see we're enabling
text auto-sizing and also Android font
metrics these font metrics are something
that developers us developers are not
you know normally exposed to it turns
out that on Android WebKit and devices
can actually set a little fudge factor
to change the size of how fonts are
rendered this is never exposed to us in
CSS or JavaScript or anything else like
that but devices have this it mostly
affects sites that do not have a meta
viewport applied so kind of desktop
sites that are viewed but luckily inside
blink and WebKit we kind of know what
all these are so we just baked him into
the emulation to make sure that the text
that you see inside emulation mode is as
close as possible as to what you would
see on the actual device all right so
I'm gonna come back here and I wanted to
talking about about another feature
that's in there and it's device pixel
ratio so my macbook is macbook air is
not a Retina machine it has a device
pixel ratio of 1 and in fact we can see
that here this page is just a really
basic demo it uses image set and we
choose the kind of asset based on the
device pixel ratio of the device and so
when I view it on my machine it's just
the 1x image that's coming in I'm gonna
open up dev tools and turn on emulation
and we're seeing 2x so the device pixel
ratio emulation captures all of this in
fact things like image set act exactly
the way you would expect window dot
device pixel ratio any device pixel
ratio media queries all of that code
that you normally that everything goes
through on on mobile browsers it's now
going through all of that in the
emulation feature inside the chrome dev
tools I took a look at a few more other
sites this is me with the Nexus S
emulating the Boston Globe and I
have an old Nexus S so I just brought
that up looking looking pretty sharp
side-by-side and then I went flower
shopping for my mom for for Thanksgiving
again we're looking very close now so
that's the thing is that we really think
that having the ability to emulate many
of the characteristics of these mobile
devices saves you a lot of time and so
you don't have always have to go down to
your actual devices one more thing this
is kind of an interesting situation this
is the chromium bug tracker as you can
see and when I resize it kind of you
know it just kind of sticks there but
interestingly he spent a lot of time in
your browser and you've experienced kind
of death pop pages especially with fixed
positioning and you zoom in I'm just
doing a shift pinch right here you'll
notice this kind of a thing happens this
is the behavior that you cannot really
emulate normally just by resizing the
window and because we have a viewport
emulation inside of this feature we can
really mimic the behavior that you get
on a phone so mobile emulation captures
your standard screen resolution the
device pixel ratio the text auto-sizing
behavior happens mostly with pages that
do not have a meta viewport set the
viewport so this is you know the
viewport width equals device width or
you're studying something else
all of that has now baked in here that's
something that we haven't been able to
do on desktop before touch events of
course including synthetic gestures like
pinch zoom and pan and in your standard
user agent string device geolocation
orientation that stuff I'm show one more
here this is a forecast IO
many people have probably seen a site
before really nice well-developed site
but it it doesn't really like my
standard approach would not probably
work here and even clicking these menus
and maps it looks like they're only
bound with touch events so it's a little
bit challenging to approach this
completely on Indust
so I'm going to turn go into dev tools
turn on emulation just give it a quick
refresh and this is looking a lot more
like what I would expect I can swipe
this out I can go into the menu even go
into the map and my touch move events
are behaving just like I would expect
alright so the mobile emulation they can
do a lot of things I'm Emily the
rendering and mobile characteristics
that you would get on many devices and
have it right here on desktop it also
see what a retina would look like on an
on retina machine and the vice versa
and identify if you know you have
different facets coming in for different
pixel ratios and I like that alright
here alright lastly iterating quickly
especially on mobile and to do this I'm
going to launch a demo and show a
feature called workspaces this is
something that we launched at Google i/o
earlier this year so I have a site
coming up okay cool html5 please is the
site but you can see I'm hosting it off
of localhost but I really want to do
some development on my phone so I can
take this over and go over to about
inspect and open up my tab and it's the
Wrights logo host 8000 on the phone is
the phone and the phone doesn't have a
web server on its so right okay cool
we'll come back here ah yes yes yes port
forwarding okay cool so let's forward
the port so right here we're gonna Ford
my machines log host 8000 send it over
to the device on it's 8,000 we'll turn
that guy on done his green lights light
up and say you're all good to go and
let's try this again
refresh
mmm nice all right all right cool so I
have my local project and I want to make
some changes I'm just gonna inspect
element on my phone and we're going to
come down here and it looks like
actually these styles are coming in from
sass right here and with this we have
source map support so actually if I just
hold down command I can click on this
property and we'll go to the original
location in the authored source where
that background was defined so it's
actually in a mixin the color looks like
it's coming in as a variable let's jump
out and command click on the color this
time ok cool cool this is a the
variables file and the color is defined
right down here and I want to change it
a little bit so let's lighten it up just
a touch one type light in and we'll go
for you know 20% and I'll just hit save
nice cool what do you think 50% a little
bit more or you know we could darken it
back up mmm yeah that's good nice so
what we're doing here is that I'm typing
sass I'm hitting save inside the dev
tools because I just navigated right
over from the style pane to my original
author code I'm hitting save I'm getting
a recompilation of that sass into the
CSS and dev tools like hey you just
change your CSS let me show it to you ok
cool so that's pretty good and this
looks looks good to me
you change one more thing about this
behavior while I'm here on my phone this
text box is it's cool but it needs a
little bit of spicing up so I'm gonna
improve things a little bit I'm going to
jump into the script file I hit command
o and jump into script chaos and I know
the function that I want to take a look
at someone hit command shift o
and dive into updates search I'm gonna
add in one little small piece of
functionality here I'm just going to
tweak things every time I change the
every time I type into the search box a
WebKit transform the prefixes are on
their way
you we're working on it all right so
this looks good to me right math not
random 360 I think I think it's gonna be
great so what I'm doing is I just
finished typing that that script out I'm
just gonna hit save and when I hit save
the new function definition gets sent to
v8 VA it's like Oh new got it
cool I'm not refreshing the page but I'm
just gonna come over here and start
typing and all right nice an improvement
right right I think so but this is
really nice I just I just updated the
sass had it show up live I just updated
the JavaScript it evaluated live I
didn't refresh the page at all and I'm
going really fast I'm liking what I'm
doing so much that I'm gonna come over
here
let's get diff yeah I just remote debug
my phone made these changes over on my
phone I mean I'm seeing it here on my
screen but the changes are also saved to
disk over in variables that has CSS I
have my change here my big CSS was
recompiled and then of course my
JavaScript changed here too so all this
is persisted did it to disk and I'm
pretty happy with it
so I'm just going to get commit so good
okay I'm not gonna because who wants
that thing to happen that's just crazy
all right cool let's come on back now
all right so the dev tools support for
sass that I showed you is not South
Pacific it's it's generalized for
anything that outputs source maps in CSS
less just added this in less 1.5 in fact
here's a quick video of this in action
this is this is
a little bootstrap Paige
coming in and and what we do is we just
select this kind of the well in
bootstrap and when you see it's a less
file we're gonna command click just like
we did before
apply a little darken function and hit
save the recompile happens we bring in
the new and CSS and you get to go really
fast I also know that uh that work is
happening to bring source maps to
autoprefixer to compass and I hear
rumors about stylus considering it as
well so all of this paints a really nice
picture of dev tools giving me a lot of
powerful features when it comes to
editing and authoring the iterating fast
all my changes can be saved to disk I'm
gonna be editing SAS and less and
getting those updates directly I can be
editing anything really in this project
c++ markdown the whole thing this also
means that if i'm authoring here inside
the dev tools i can also be placing
breakpoints this is really nice i hit
breakpoints I find my bug I fix it I hit
command s and v8 immediately gets that
new thing I then see that the bug is
gone and I'm all good I never had to
refresh the page at all so I get the
nice live edit reevaluation right on the
fly if you make a mistake and you don't
want that change command z all your way
back works everywhere and I can do all
this while in road debugging it's the
same powerful feature set on the phone
so a lot of what I showed today is
newish and in fact there's a brand new
beta for chrome and Android version 32
shipping today so I encourage you to
grab that if you want to be able to
replicate everything that I showed and
of course everything is moving very fast
on desktop the mobile mobile emulation
features that I showed have been landing
over the past few weeks and there's some
great stuff so definitely grab Chrome
Canary and check out the latest and
greatest there and I was like putting
together kind of this presentation and I
took a step back and I just like had
this Keanu moment and I was
Wow because I was like I now have this
like insight as to what are the actual
GPU characteristics on the phone and I
can see that happening these things I
didn't even show this is a flame chart
of the JavaScript evaluation of a WebGL
experience and I can see what my most
expensive functions are and quickly
drill into that very quickly or do a
canvas or WebGL profile and gain insight
into the characteristics of how that's
actually executing it's a lot going on
is moving fast but all in all it's
giving you a lot of insight and how to
make user experiences across multiple
device that are fluid fast and awesome
so a lot of this is documented at dev
tools chrome comm I encourage you to
check that out and please if you have
any bugs feature quests anything for the
dev tools holler it means let me know
I'll make it happen I'll do my best
and thank you guys very much